but first buckin palace has confirmed
that Prince Harry and Megan will lose
royal funds and will no longer use their
HRH titles from this spring the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex will also reap a 2.4
million pounds that taxpayers spent
renovating their Berkshire home
Frogmore cottage and of course this all
comes after they went public with their
wish to step back as senior Royals
joining us to discuss this and much more
as the Conservative Party Chairman James
Kelly thank you very much for being here
with us on this morning so how do you
feel about Prince Harry and Megan
stepping back from their all duties well
I mean ultimately this is a decision for
them and Her Majesty the Queen and the
royal family and I understand that not
everyone wants to live their lives in
that you know the media bubble and with
that level of intense scrutiny and
that's that's completely that's
completely understandable and I'm really
glad that they've come to an arrangement
that clearly the Queen is happy with and
they're happy with I mean there's some
big questions for the country taxpayers
as well aren't there I mean if they're
spending their time or the majority of
their time in North America who should
be footing the bill for security well we
don't ever the government doesn't ever
discuss personal security arrangements I
think people understand why why that's
the case even just on their share
question of who's gonna pay for it yeah
we don't discuss it at all I think it's
it's it's really important that these
arrangements are kept private and and so
yeah I won't be drawn on that Laura but
why does the cost need to be kept
private I understand of the details of
course of the security well because the
cost implies detail okay now last year
and we did a podcast with you we'd had a
quick fire round in that podcast and one
of the questions we asked was William in
Kate or Harry a Megan at the time you
said Harry a Megan are you still on Team
Harry and Megan well this is this is
it's really interesting because of
course you know Harry didn't choose the
life that he was born into and we could
see that he was clearly very happy being
a soldier and I think sometimes less
happy as I say without very intense
public scrutiny and I've got sympathy
yeah and I do think ultimately
you know if family is really important
and his you know his wife and his child
are really important to him and I think
if if if they're funny away that that
works for them and the queen is happy
then I think we should be happy when we
spoken a bit though about the the media
scrutiny and the intensity of that I
mean summer said that Megan's been the
victim of racism is that something that
you recognize or I think I think the
this country is one of the least racist
one of the most open and welcoming
countries in the world and that's
reinforced by things like the British
attitude survey and a whole load of
international surveys about people's
acceptance of other other races but you
know she was she was subjects it's a
huge amount of media interest and that
can be really difficult to deal with and
if they choose a life that means they
don't have to deal with that I think we
should respect that and then just kind
of finally on this and topic and the
actor Lourdes Fox was on question time
this week and one of the audience
members and was talking about how she
believed that making her being a victim
of racism he disagreed and then she said
that because he was a white privilege
male he has no experience in this this
is what Lawrence Fox said in response he
said I can't help what I am I was born
like this it's an immutable
characteristic so to call me a white
privilege male is to be racist you're
being racist do you agree with Lawrence
Fox that I think I mean I think that was
a little rhetorical flourish I think
there is a point about saying that if
you haven't had a lived experience you
cannot comment at all on certain issues
I'm a bit uncomfortable with that I'm
not entirely convinced that that is the
most pernicious form of racism that
we've that we've seen ever but I do
think that we ever e1 should have the
right to an opinion irrespective of your
background I think one of the things
that we need to encourage is for people
to disagree with a bit more dignity and
that disagreement not being quite so
aggressive or personal I think that's
something that a lot of people would
would hope to see
and you know Lawrence was was clearly on
that program he was he was there to
entertain he's an actor and entertainer
and I think he was very entertaining not
if I always agreed with him okay
entertaining interesting words she's
there now keeps me you've always talked
about some policies that your government
is and fishing and today you're looking
to give police more powers when it comes
to stalking what exactly is it that
you're trying to do well what we know is
a huge number of people have to endure
stalking a much larger percentage than I
think most people would would realize
and it's it's something that no one
should have to deal with we want to give
more powers to the police and the courts
and stalking protection orders is the
vehicle that we are bringing forward so
from tomorrow what the courts will be
able to do is apply stalking protection
order which will limit what someone can
do in terms of the how they approach or
proximity all that kind of stuff and if
they're breached the courts and the
police can take action and that will
protect people and there have been
occasions where where people's lives
have been taken by stalkers I mean want
to protect people from and and we're
gonna be discussing this and more later
from the program as well and with one of
the and police and crime and
commissioners really important issue and
as you say another policy that's in the
newspapers today in the Sunday Times is
this notion that the House of Lords is
gonna be moved uprooted from Westminster
and moved to either York or potentially
Birmingham is that right well what we
are looking at is a whole range of
options about making sure that every
part of the UK feels properly connected
from politics when the Prime Minister
stood up the day after general election
and said this is going to be the
People's Government he meant it and that
meant connecting people with government
and with politics because the referendum
in 2016 wasn't just about our
relationship with the EU it was about
millions of people and their
relationship with politics as a whole as
we're looking at a whole range of ways
of connecting people in the kind of
places where we won representation for
the first time in decades
is it going to happen then I mean could
we see the House of Lords and being in a
different place
bye we might again we might it's one of
a range of things that we are we're
looking into but fundamentally what this
is about is it's about demonstrating to
people that we are going to do things
differently the Labour Party lost
millions of voters because they failed
to listen and to address I mean you've
got the kind of majority where you can
be radical just do it Oh trust me we're
gonna be radical we are going to get
stuff done
the Prime Minister is absolutely clear
and this is very much the the the focus
of the government it's about delivering
and it's about delivering for the people
of this country
north-south-east-west me Oh England
Scotland Wales Northern Ireland we are
absolutely in delivery mode on the House
of Lords and their bid reports as well
in Sunday Times that jeremy corbyn's
gonna be nominating john Barco for a
peerage a former speaker do you think
he'd be a good person to be sitting in
the house floors
well again i'm gonna fall back on
convention here by vitac invention we
don't discuss the via peerages and
nominations before before the event so
I'm going to I'm going to seem in
principle do you think that John back
home he's a very experienced he's a very
experienced politician that's definitely
in well behaved modus is you've got on
the reshuffle here you like to hang onto
your job or something no I mean the the
simple facts of the matter is that you
know the nominations process is always a
lot of speculation is always good fun
until it actually comes out we won't
know exactly who has been put forward
and you people all your viewers very
well informed they can speculate all on
their own they don't need me to help
them speculate okay and now we're
talking about you're promising that the
government is going to be radical that
you only focused on delivery I mean some
people would be questioning why we are
embroiled in a row over whether Big Ben
should bomb for brexit and it's worth
pointing out that this was effectively
started by the prime minister when he
asked people to donate to make Big Ben
Charmin brexit day even though it's
gonna cost potentially half a million
pounds and even though the House of
Commons might not even be able to accept
the money anyway
ridiculous well I think there has I mean
the the year the Prime Minister made a
light-hearted statement about about Big
Ben trust me this is not
the this is not the most pressing issue
in in government it generates a lot of
interest of course it does and it's good
from and it's good media knockabout but
using some money to prove your brother -
no I'm not that any money i donate will
be to two other good causes what about
Andrew lesson she's only forking out my
Tanner is that insufficient cano
everyone whatever everyone's everyone's
philanthropic hats are up to them but I
mean that it's a good fun story and it
is a fun so it's a light-hearted story
but ultimately this is this is not this
is not I don't I can assure you the main
focus of government so Boris Johnson
hasn't asked the captain to chip in then
he's not asked me now okay
now there's another story that I am keen
to are about in your role as
Conservative Party Chairman and that's
Jamie Wallace the newly elected MP for
Bridgend now he was allegedly involved
in sugar daddy website now he's denied
it since then more information has come
to light we're trying to get hold of his
office we haven't received anything and
at the time that we're talking about it
now now the website asked are you a
student a single parent or too short of
money and then it claimed we can
introduce you to your very own sugar
daddy and solve your money worries
mm-hmm are you looking into these
reports that one of your newly elected
MPs was allegedly involved in this well
I mean the the activities that website
is not something I'm at all comfortable
with but ultimately the the relationship
between you know that company and any
companies that Jamie might have been
involved in is something that that I'm
not in a position to look into that the
business arrangements are separate and
if he has done anything wrong that will
be looked at by by the whips but at this
stage I don't know that he has done you
know anything anything wrong and the
exact relationship between him and
various businesses I'm not I don't have
full details of that yeah I mean it's
details that you could have try and get
because I understand of course you're
saying that you know this is not
completely a matter for the conservative
part of it whether or not he has the
witness well that is that's something as
I say that without knowing and it's it's
difficult for me to say oh the
that's he's done something right he's
done something wrong because I don't
have the full detail of the well because
it's not actually cuz it's it's not my
job if if if it's presented to me that
he has done something wrong as it is the
case with all members of the party if
something's presented to us as a party
saying look this person that has done
something wrong then we will take action
but we're not an investigation unit it
is not our job to start looking into the
speculatively looking to the business
arrangements of members of the party or
members of parliament why not be
proactive here we are you a student a
single parent what a short of money what
does it say his relationship with
businesses that he's run all other
businesses I don't have the details of
that and as I say we're not win we are
it is not our role to go looking for a
relationship or business relationship or
trawl through business records if
something is presented to us where where
someone has done something wrong as we
always do we will take action okay okay
now talking we were talking about
earlier about other potential of a
reshuffle and we're hearing is gonna be
come in the coming weeks and you worried
about keeping your own job well I think
I've always I've always had a philosophy
that if you've got a job to do get on
with that job do it well and if that is
recognized that's fantastic so yeah and
I think that I think the idea that
people in a row whatever that role is
should should do anything other than
focus on delivering on their on their
remit is you know is nonsense that's
just how that's how every organisation
I've ever been in every successful
organisation I've ever been in focuses
have a job to do do that can you confirm
it's happening next month then well we
already know that the department for
exiting the European Union will be
closing down it has delivered on its
mandate and the team there have done
what's been asked of them so there's
going to have to be a degree of
reorganization but I'm not involved in
in planning of that
and you know I don't know I don't know
how extensive or otherwise any changes
in government will be you're expecting
to be next month oh well as I say I mean
Dex you Dex you is is gonna be finishing
when it has completed its job so there
is inevitably going to have to be some
kind of change after that okay and then
just finally we're of course covering
the Labour leadership contest on the
show we'll be hearing my interview with
Jeff Phillips bit later on um as a
chairman of the Conservative Party which
candidate you most afraid of fighting at
a general election well I'm not oh you
know I I don't have a view this is for
the this is for the Labour Party this is
for the Labour Party to decide but one
of the points on one of the points one
of the points the Labour Party's got to
decide is are they gonna start listening
because when I was when I was
campaigning across the country including
in many labour heartlands the message I
got back over and over again was the
Labour Party had stopped listening to
voters so my only piece of advice
whoever does get it is if I want any
chance of being successful they need to
do what the the Conservatives did at
this election which is to listen to
people okay
James Kelly thank you very much indeed
James Kelly